When was the last time
that you did nothing?
And by nothing,
I really mean nothing.
Hi, I’m Andy,
and welcome to
Headspace Guide to Meditation.
Throughout this series,
I’m going to be your guide
as we explore the mind
and discover how meditation
can benefit us in our life.
In each episode, I’m going
to introduce a new technique
and tell you how that technique
can be used for specific situations.
I hope meditation can bring you
a greater sense of presence
in your life,
a greater ability
to not be distracted,
to enjoy life
and to connect with the people
that you care about most.
The best way of experiencing
meditation is to actually do it,
not to just talk about it.
We’re going to start
with the eyes open,
and a nice, soft focus,
just aware of the space around you.
And just take a moment,
before you do anything else…
just to appreciate
and enjoy that feeling
of having stopped.